queimação nos pés mas não tenho dor eu
só sinto eles queimando o que pode ser
primeira coisa uma alteração dos nervos
principalmente dos nervos mais fininhos
do finalzinho ali do nervo né dos nervos
periféricos então uma doença dos nervos
uma
neuropatia pode ser por lesão por
diabetes por reumatismo por uma
alteração da circulação principalmente
arterial ou seja o que leva a oxigenação
certo uso inadequado de sapatos Então
dependendo às vezes da anatomia do pé
desse paciente ele tá usando sapatos que
não são adequados causando o quê um
incômodo um apertamento às vezes até uma
fadiga muscular Tá certo outra coisa
importante é a falta de hidratação
também pode dar queimação na sola dos
pés Tá certo então déf de vitaminas
doenças metabólicas sapatos inadequados
longa permanência em
pé tudo isso pode gerar uma queimação na
sola dos pés